Cuando nos contactábamos con ellos, les seguíamos sirviendo comida a diario
así que necesitábamos más lugar, y nos trasladamos al estadio Coliseo.
Los 25 000 platos se convirtieron en 50 000,
y de golpe pasó a ser el restaurante más grande del mundo.
Preparábamos unas 70 000 comidas al día
desde una sola ubicación.
(Aplausos)
Empezaron a llegar cientos de voluntarios.
En un momento llegamos a tener más de 7000 voluntarios
que trabajaban con nosotros como mínimo una hora o más,
y en cualquier momento siempre había más de 700 personas trabajando a la vez.
Y así empezamos a crear un movimiento
con una simple idea a la que todo el mundo podía unirse:
alimentar a los necesitados.
Empezamos a crear platos que la gente pudiera reconocer,
no como esa comida que viene de lugares remotos,
en bolsas de plástico, que cuando las abres ni siquiera puedes oler.
(Risas)
Cocinábamos platos para que la gente se sintiera como en casa.
En ese momento, esas personas tenían la necesidad de sentirse vivas,
de sentirse queridas.
Una comida, en ese momento,
no solo era algo con lo que aportar calorías al cuerpo,
calorías que necesitaban,
sino que necesitaban algo más.
Querían saber que todos
se preocupaban por ellos,
que les estábamos diciendo:
"Estamos con Uds. Les pedimos un tiempo, estamos tratando de arreglar esto".
Y eso es lo que nos encontrábamos cada vez que llegábamos a un sitio.
Empezaron a traer fruta fresca,
y en la FEMA me preguntaban:
"José, ¿cómo consigues la comida?".
"Fácil: llamas, pagas y la tienes".
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Primero, abastecimos San Juan.
Sin darnos cuenta, alimentábamos a los 78 municipios de la isla.
Pero necesitábamos un plan. Una sola cocina no alimentaría a una isla.
Fui a la FEMA y ocho guardias armados con fusiles me echaron.
Les dije: "Quiero 18 cocinas repartidas por toda la isla".
Adivinen qué. Hace tres días abrimos la 18ª cocina
en Puerto Rico.
(Aplausos)
La gente empezaba a sentirse nutrida.
Seguían presentándose voluntarios.
La gente me dirá que nunca tuvimos un sistema de reparto de alimentos.
¡Claro que lo tuvimos!
La isla entera de Puerto Rico era el sistema de reparto perfecto.
Cualquiera con un camión podía ayudar.
Cualquiera que pudiera desplazarse de un lado a otro, era señal de esperanza
y significaba un plato con comida para alguien.
Desarrollamos sistemas increíbles para usar camiones de comida;
diez camiones fantásticos.
Empezamos a aprender a no usar el lugar donde la gente necesitaba comida,
sino el número,
el número de vivienda:
"Lolo, veterano de 92 años, atrapado por el agua".
No solo repartíamos esperanza a la gente,
sino que sabíamos sus nombres,
los visitábamos todos los días,
asegurándonos de que esa gente mayor jamás se volviera a sentir sola
en momentos angustiosos.
Luego nos adentramos en las áreas más profundas,
lugares donde, de repente, los puentes se habían caído.
Pero había que ir, porque era fácil quedarse en San Juan.
Debíamos ir a esos lugares que realmente nos necesitaban.
Y seguimos adelante,
y la gente seguía esperándonos porque sabía que apareceríamos,
que nunca los íbamos a dejar solos.
(Aplausos)
Los camiones de comida se convirtieron en nuestros salvadores,
siempre repartiendo esperanza,
pero había que hacer más:
Vieques y Culebra, dos islas lejos de Puerto Rico,
necesitaban que alguien las alimentara.
Repartimos alimentos y construimos una cocina en un hotel de Vieques
y suministramos comida a Culebra.
Además, construimos el primer sistema de purificación de agua
en la isla de Vieques,
donde podíamos depurar 3,7 litros de agua por minuto.
De pronto, grandes problemas se volvieron muy simples,
con soluciones fáciles,
poniendo manos a la obra, sin planes ni reuniones en grandes edificios.
(Risas)
Y luego pensamos de forma creativa.
Necesitábamos helicópteros: los pedimos y los obtuvimos.
Necesitábamos aviones: pedimos, pagamos y los conseguimos.
Así, seguimos distribuyendo comida a las zonas realmente necesitadas.
Una simple idea se convirtió en algo poderoso.
Los voluntarios iban hasta los extremos de la isla.
De pronto, habíamos creado un movimiento.
Los equipos de 'World Central Kitchen'
eran recibidos con oraciones, con canciones, con aplausos,
con abrazos, con sonrisas.
Hicimos tantas conexiones en tantos sitios...
Créanme cuando les digo, que incluso la Guardia Nacional nos llamó
porque los pobres Guardias,
grandes héroes dentro del caos,
no tenían ni un simple plato de comida caliente.
Y surgieron colaboraciones:
la ONG filantrópica Mercy Corps,
HSI, la sección de investigaciones de la Seguridad Nacional,
colaboraciones que no surgieron por contactos en las altas esferas.
Surgieron en una habitación de hotel,
en medio de la calle, en las montañas.
Comprendimos que, trabajando juntos, podíamos llegar a más gente.
Colaboraciones que tienen una lógica,
y donde la urgencia del momento está al servicio de la gente.
Las organizaciones de ayuda humanitaria para emergencias
no podemos pararnos a pensar cómo vamos a auxiliar dentro de un mes.
Tenemos que estar preparados para actuar
el segundo después de que algo suceda.
Los niños estaban alimentados,
y de repente, la isla,
todavía en una situación muy delicada
donde todo es frágil...
No queríamos que una ONG como la nuestra
destruyera el sector privado.
Vimos que estaban abriendo pequeños restaurantes.
Que de alguna manera la normalidad,
o lo que se entiende por normalidad hoy en Puerto Rico, estaba volviendo.
Entonces empezamos a comunicar la idea
de que debíamos empezar a alejarnos de los sitios que ya estaban normalizados
y continuar nuestra tarea en las áreas que realmente lo requerían.
(Video) ¡Gente de Puerto Rico! ¡Dos millones de platos!
Vale, permítanme que les explique esto.
(Risas)
Al cabo de casi 28 días,
más de 10 camiones de comida,
más de 7000 voluntarios,
18 cocinas...
servimos más de dos millones de platos.
(Aplausos)
Y Uds., que vienen a TED, siéntanse orgullosos,
porque ya conocemos a muchos de Uds., y Uds. son parte del cambio.
Pero el cambio solo sucederá, si después de abandonar la conferencia
ponemos en práctica las ideas y el entusiasmo que tenemos
y creemos que nada es imposible,
y ponemos nuestro conocimiento al servicio de aquellos que lo necesitan.
Llegué a una isla para darle de comer a unas cuantas personas
y vi que había un gran problema,
y de pronto, la gente de Puerto Rico vio el mismo problema que yo,
e hicimos una sola cosa:
nos pusimos a cocinar.
Así, los puertorriqueños
y los chefs de Puerto Rico en un momento de desolación,
empezaron a sembrar esperanza.
Sin necesidad de reunirse
o de hacer planes,
tan solo con una simple idea:
vamos a cocinar y a alimentar
a la gente de Puerto Rico.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Dave Troy: Vuelve, vuelve.
(Risas)
DT: El público te quiere.
(Aplausos)
Nate Mook: Solo un par de preguntas,
que creo que a la gente le interesará escuchar.
Como has dicho, llegaste por primera vez,
reconociste el terreno,
fuiste a la sede del gobierno,
tuviste reuniones con algunas personas,
y no estuvieron muy dispuestas a escuchar.
José A.: ¡Genial! Parece que mi charla estuvo muy buena.
(Risas)
Es la primera la charla TED con aclaración de la historia.
Me siento tan bien...
(Risas)
NM: Cuéntanos cuáles fueron algunos de los retos,
y cuándo percibiste que empezaban a recurrir a ti, a pedirte ayuda.
JA: No podemos pedirle todo a la Cruz Roja o al Ejército de Salvación.
Pero la idea es que yo he hecho donaciones a estas organizaciones en el pasado,
y son organizaciones importantes
y tal vez el problema es que esperamos demasiado de ellas.
No es que no hicieron lo que tenían que hacer.
El problema es la expectativa que tenemos de estas organizaciones.
Pero en un momento como este no puedes de repente lavarte las manos,
y decir que va a venir otro a arreglarlo.
Teníamos un problema muy simple con una solución muy sencilla.
No se trataba de un país lejano
o la Zona Verde en Baghdad.
Era EE. UU.,
un hermoso lugar llamado Puerto Rico,
con cientos, miles de restaurantes y gente dispuesta a echar una mano,
pero de pronto, teníamos gente hambrienta,
y no teníamos ni idea de cómo servirles en el corto plazo.
Y sí, FEMA, de alguna manera, pensaba cómo alimentar a esa gente.
La Cruz Roja no tenía una buena solución,
porque la Convención Bautista del Sur, el mayor banco de alimentos de EE. UU.,
mis héroes, nunca fueron convocados a Puerto Rico.
Cuando la Cruz Roja reparte alimentos después de un huracán en EE. UU.,
en realidad es la Convención Bautista del Sur.
Pero en Puerto Rico no pasó eso.
El Ejército de Salvación pidió 420 platos una noche lluviosa de miércoles
para un centro de ancianos.
A mí me encanta ayudarles,
pero según mi criterio, son ellos los que se supone que deberían ayudarnos
a responder a esos gritos de auxilio.
El jueves por la mañana me levanto preocupadísimo
porque aún no habíamos pensado cómo íbamos a alimentar a la isla.
Y algunos dirán que estoy haciendo el problema
más grande de lo que era.
Teníamos cientos y cientos de organizaciones
tocando la puerta para pedirnos una bandeja de comida.
Así que ahí está la prueba de que la pobreza era real.
No podemos seguir alimentando a EE. UU. con comida preparada
o algo que lo abres y... ya saben.
Le di esa misma comida a los gatos,
(Risas)
y después les di pollo y arroz del que hicimos,
y al final comían el pollo y el arroz.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
¡No quisieron la otra comida!
Se puede subsistir a base de eso durante un día, dos o cinco,
pero esas comidas preparadas cuestan unos 12,14,15 o 20 dólares
y las pagan los contribuyentes.
Va bien en ciertas ocasiones,
durante la guerra,
pero no para alimentar a la población durante semanas y semanas,
y más cuando se puede contratar a una empresa local privada
para que haga el mismo trabajo, mucho mejor, creando puestos de trabajo,
ayudando a la economía local a recuperarse,
para que todo vuelva a la normalidad
lo más rápido posible.
Por eso empezamos a cocinar.
Tú estabas ahí conmigo.
Y por eso nos gastamos hasta el último dólar en las tarjetas.
Si American Express nos está escuchando, un descuento no nos vendría mal.
(Risas)
O Visa.
NM: ¿Cuál es la situación ahora?
Ha pasado un mes,
has dicho que ha habido algunas mejoras en San Juan
y un foco de trabajo en las afueras,
pero evidentemente aún quedan retos.
¿Qué es lo siguiente?
JA: Lo siguiente es que de a poco empezamos a reducir el servicio,
desde que la FEMA nos dijo más o menos
que pensaban que ya tenían todo controlado
y que no nos necesitaban más.
Pero solo te crees las cosas hasta un cierto punto...
Nos trasladamos del lugar que han visto, donde servíamos 60 000 platos,
a otro, igual de grande, pero mejor localizado,
y también más barato,
donde vamos a cocinar entre 20 y 25 mil platos diarios.
Y también dejamos montadas cuatro, cinco, seis cocinas
estratégicamente ubicadas por la isla,
en lo alto de las montañas, en las áreas pobres.
Tenemos mucha información.
Sabemos quién recibe el Programa Asistencial de Nutrición Suplementaria,
los cupones para alimentos.
Sabemos quién los tiene y quién los usa.
Así que en las partes de la isla donde nadie los usa,
esas son las zonas donde enfocamos nuestros esfuerzos.
Es increíble cómo, a veces, tener información te da pistas
sobre quiénes son los necesitados.
Así que fuimos a la ciudad de Morovis.
Preciosa.
Tiene el mejor restaurante de pollo de la historia.
Deberían ir a Morovis.
DT: Suena bien.
JA: Vi el pollo mientras llevaba unos sándwiches y paré.
Iba con unos oficiales de la Seguridad Nacional.
Paramos y comimos el pollo.
Y luego nos fuimos a llevar los sándwiches a otro lugar llamado San Lorenzo.
San Lorenzo estaba en crisis porque el puente se había caído
entonces era una isla dentro de otra,
una pequeña comunidad rodeada de agua.
Todo el mundo nos decía: "¡Aquello es un desastre!".
Entregamos los sándwiches,
volví a Morovis y pensé:
"¿Saben qué? Si es un "desastre", con sándwiches no alcanza".
Compré 120 pollos,
y yuca, y arroz,
y volvimos al puente roto,
cruzamos el río,
con el agua hasta arriba por todos lados,
llegamos con los 120 pollos,
entregamos la comida,
y muy agradecidos, nos dijeron:
"Estamos bien, no precisamos más comida.
Tenemos gas, tenemos dinero,
tenemos buena comida y agua limpia también.
Ocúpense de otras comunidades que lo necesitan más".
¿Ven? La comunicación es clave.
En ocasiones como esta, podemos fiarnos de noticias falsas
o podemos obtener información real para tomar decisiones inteligentes
y ocuparnos de los verdaderos problemas.
Y eso es lo que hacemos.
(Aplausos)
NM: Fue un trabajo increíble,
y un placer ser testigo de primera mano y aportar un granito de arena.
JA: Lo hiciste posible.
NM: En un momento llegaste a cocinar cerca de 150 000 comidas al día,
alrededor de la isla,
lo que es realmente increíble.
Y al mismo tiempo pienso que estableciste un modelo
de cómo se puede hacer esto en el futuro.
Creo que esa es la lección que nos enseña esto.
DT: Claro. Esto es algo posible, que se puede reproducir.
JA: Ah, pero voy a dejar de venir a las charlas TED,
porque después Uds. piensan que cualquier cosa es posible.
(Risas)
Y después mi mujer me dirá:
"Me dijiste que ibas a cocinar mil platos en un día,
¡no puedo dejarte solo un día!".
(Risas)
Pero espero que 'World Central Kitchen'...
Ah, hay una cosa que hicimos que no les conté:
levanté el teléfono y empecé a llamar gente.
Gente que yo pensaba que tenía la experiencia para poder ayudarnos.
así que llamé a una empresa llamada 'Bon Appétit, Fedele'.
Bon Appétit es una empresa de comidas muy grande.
Hacen comida para Google, y para los estadios, y cosas así.
Tienen sede en California.
Son parte de grupo más grande llamado 'Compass'.
Y les dije: "¿Saben qué?
Necesito cocineros que puedan cocinar grandes cantidades.
Comida buena y de calidad, en grandes cantidades".
En menos de 24 horas, conseguí gente y chefs que me ayudaron.
En un momento dispuse de 16 de los mejores chefs de EE. UU.
Es que EE. UU. es un país fraternal
que siempre contribuye con lo mejor sí.
Con los años hemos aprendido
que estos chefs de EE. UU. tendrán un papel importante
en el desarrollo de las actividades para alimentar EE. UU. y otros países
en tiempos de hambruna.
Lo que hay que empezar a hacer es llevar la experiencia adecuada
a los lugares donde es necesaria.
A veces tengo la sensación, como cuando fui a la FEMA,
de que llevamos la experiencia inadecuada adonde ni siquiera es necesaria.
Los de la FEMA son gente estupenda.
Son inteligentes,
están preparados,
pero viven bajo esa asombrosa organización jerárquica piramidal
donde todos caen por su propio peso.
Hay que empoderar a la gente para que pueda alcanzar el éxito.
Nosotros diseñamos un organigrama más llano
en el que todos eran dueños de la situación
y todos tomábamos decisiones rápidas, solucionando los problemas de inmediato.
(Aplausos)
DT: Definitivamente.
Otro fuerte aplauso para José Andrés.
(Aplausos)